Now you might have
seen this demo before.
It's one we've featured on
the channel a few times.
But you get a big,
strong neodymium magnet
like this and a nice
thick-walled aluminium tube.
And it takes a surprisingly
long time to fall through.
Now the explanation
for that is to do
with how the magnet induces
electric currents in the tube.
And those currents have
their own magnetic field.
And those two magnetic fields
interact with each other
to create a force.
I go into a bit more detail
with that explanation in one
of the other videos if
you're interested in that.
But if I do it again
and look down the tube,
I can see the magnet
isn't actually
touching the sides at all.
So there's an interesting
question there,
which is what would happen
to the weight of the tube
if I were measuring it while the
magnet was falling through it?
Would it increase?
Would it decrease?
What would happen?
And there's only one way
to find out the answer
to that question, and
that's to do the experiment.
So I got my balance.
And first of all, I
need to protect it
from the intensely strong
magnet that I've got here.
So a roll of tape, and I'm
going to put the tube on,
and let's see what happens.
So there you go.
The weight went up
to about 370 grammes.
And it did that while
the magnet was falling.
And it hasn't really
gone up any more
now that the magnet is resting
on the plastic at the bottom.
So there's the answer.
The weight does go up.
The effective weight
of the tube does go up
with a magnet
falling through it.
So why is that?
Why does that happen?
Well, to answer that
question, you kinda
need to understand a little
bit about what weight is.
So weight is a force.
In particular, it's
a force that makes
things accelerate
towards the ground.
So if I take this ball of
string here and let go, [THUMP],
when I release it, it
accelerates towards the ground.
Now the flip side of that
is that whenever anything
isn't accelerating towards
the ground, when this
pen on the table with
the aluminium tube,
whenever anything
isn't accelerating,
that means there must be another
force, another force that
is supporting the
weight of that object.
So with me, the floor
is supporting my weight
and I'm not
accelerating anywhere.
So when the magnet is
falling through the tube,
the fact that it's
not accelerating
means that something must
be supporting its weight.
And that force in fact is
the magnetic interaction
between the magnet
and the currents
that are set up in the tube.
But we know from
Newton's Third Law,
if there's a force acting on the
magnet supporting it's weight,
there must be an equal force
acting downwards on the tube.
And that force is what is being
transmitted through the tube
into the balance.
And that's what we read on
the display of the balance.
And sure enough, if we measure
the weight of the magnet now,
we can see, surprise,
surprise, the weight
it's reading is
that 370-odd grammes
that we saw reading
while the magnet was
falling through the tube.